fifty percent of men and women will not
or do not look at themselves in the
mirror because they do not like the
person that they see and if you can't
even look yourself in the eyes in the
mirror that is a habit of self-rejection
that means you are starting your day by
rejecting yourself and that's why so
many of us race out into the world and
seek validation from partners and
friends because we haven't even given
ourself the respect we deserve and so I
want to teach you how to bring it back
home because for those of us that look
in the mirror we see the things we don't
like this is part of your morning
routine this is the part where you stand
in front of the mirror and just trash
yourself we're going to change that
using science what I want you to do is
you're going to look yourself in the
eyes take a minute that's not a
reflection that's a human being in the
mirror and she needs you she is tired of
Bob running
in your head she's working hard she
needs you to show up and then you are
going to raise your hand it's cheesy as
it sounds and you're going to high-five
the woman you see in the mirror that's
it do not say a word do not have a
mantra because your brain isn't ready
for it yet need motivation you better
watch a top ten We Believe Nation hey
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Mel Robbins and my take on
her top 10 rules for success
enjoy
I want you to turn to the person next to
you we're going to count backwards of
five and then we're going to give each
other a high five and I'll explain
something ready turn to the person next
to you yeah I don't don't I was like
here we go five four three two one okay
great okay so let me tell you what's
going on here let me tell you which I
know we gotta wrap it up okay what's
going on here is
never in the history of high fives have
you high-fived somebody and thought I
hate you
you look terrible today
if you're in a sports team and you screw
up a shot and you come back to a huddle
what do you hope your coach and your
teammates say to you
guys yeah and if they hand you a high
five to send you back in the game what
does a high five say
good effort I believe in you keep going
I you know like on and on it is always
positive
remember how I talked about the fact
that your brain is a pattern learning
machine your brain knows the pattern of
a high five
it has a lifetime of experience with
them so all the programming's here
everybody when you stand in front of a
mirror and you physically do a high five
it grabs all the neural Association in
your brain and it aims it at your face
literally it shuts down Bob broccoli
tomato Maria whatever we're Karen you
know that we're saying the name is
shuts it down because you can't think
something negative while you're doing
this because your brain won't allow it
it's not programmed that way
it takes less than five days
for you to be able to stare at yourself
in the mirror and see a woman that
you're rooting for
your brain every time you do it gives
you a drip of dopamine that's why you
guys laughed it's not from the slap of
the hand it's what your brain's doing
you feel a little bit energized don't
you
that is your nervous system giving you a
little jolt of energy
the five second rule five four three two
one and a high five in the mirror after
you brush your teeth are two free
science-backed tools
that you can use to interrupt old
patterns that are holding you back and
to start to create new ones that will
push you forward
because that is where you're headed
We're Not Looking Back
I want you to look forward
and I want you to
quiet the noise shut it down in your
head and listen to what's in your heart
and in your gut because that's what's
meant for you
and all you have to do is wake up every
day and if yesterday blue okay it was
whatever we're gonna shake it off we're
going to high-five that off you didn't
go to the gym no problem you're still
going to give yourself a high five today
you didn't make that phone call you said
no problem you still get a high five
today because you need to send yourself
into the game of life every day knowing
that you have your own back that you
believe in you and the way that you
prove that is through the actions that
you take
and 30 minutes a day
just for you
to focus on you to set your day up
because how you set your day up is how
it ends up
you deserve that
and that's how you claim it
and trust me you're never going to feel
like it but I want you to do it anyway
you got it
good
awesome rule number two Master
visualization if you expect to achieve
your goals if you expect to
reach your potential if you expect to
have your dreams come true what I'm
about to explain to you is Mission
critical you must become a master at
visualization
now
for those of you
that are like what the heck is she
talking about I did not sign up for some
sort of meditation woo-woo spiritual
thing here
don't worry this is Mel Robbins there's
always science and research involved in
everything that I talk about
so visualization
extraordinarily powerful skill
and you may have heard of the law of
attraction
you may have heard of the word
visualization you may have heard of the
word manifesting
I call it
um
seeing signs
so I'm a master at seeing positive signs
I am a master of creating coincidences I
have the world's most incredible luck
you want to know why because I
understand the science and the skill of
visualization
know that your brain it is a gigantic
detective machine your brain is a filter
your brain is constantly looking for
evidence and that's good news it's good
news when you know how to use it to your
advantage let me explain
so your brain has a system in it here's
the technical term it's called the
reticular activating system
it is a network of neurons all up in
here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system it is a
filter system
it's basically a system that allows
certain information in your brain and it
blocks out other information
and guess who programmed that filter you
did and so did the people from your past
and so if you constantly feel like
you're unlovable guess what your
reticular activating system is going
through the day and it is going to point
out every single piece of evidence that
confirms that negative belief that you
have if you think that people don't like
you at work the reticular activating
system the filter it is literally going
to be looking for evidence to confirm
that belief all day long this is one of
the reasons why we have such a problem
with politics in this country this is
why there's something called a
confirmation bias confirmation bias
means your mind loves to read things
that you agree with because reading
things that you agree with confirms your
filter why do we have a particular
activating system there's a really
important reason why you have this the
reason why is if your brain let in
everything
have you ever looked
at a Facebook page
have you noticed how many words are on a
standard Facebook page and the ad over
here and the ad over here and the ad
over here and the ad in the zoo seed
right here and the stuff up here and all
this over here
if your brain took in everything at
equal value your head would literally
explode off your shoulders your brain
would melt down and so the reticular
activating system
protects your brain by filtering
information and only letting in stuff
that it agrees with so
that's the scientific reason and mandate
for why you got to get busy
reprogramming that thing because if you
live like I have lived for a very long
time one of the beliefs that I had we're
going to be talking about this a lot
this month one of the beliefs that I had
for a very long time is that I was a bad
person
that I was not lovable that
um I did not deserve to be a good person
that people didn't think I was a good
person and consequently that led me to
do a lot of hurtful things to myself it
led me to do a lot of hurtful things to
uh people that I cared about and it it
really damaged Decades of my life and I
believed it I believed it and it drove
my actions and I saw evidence everywhere
if you're going to do a mindset reset
you've got to change what you believe
about yourself and so for those of you
that had a very negative uh assessment
of 2018 and you're feeling down about
your goals already as you look at 2019
you have a very negative belief system
about yourself and that's going to stop
right now rule number three learn to let
go letting go is really really hard
and when you are going to start a new
chapter in your life when you're going
to try to launch yourself forward it
requires you to let go and the reason
why letting go of
whatever it may be a relationship a
friendship a job my case the place that
you lived for the 24 years the reason
why letting go is so hard is because we
tend to grip very tightly to things that
are familiar
and when you grip really tightly to the
things that you know
it's going to be really hard in fact
it's going to be impossible to launch
yourself forward
and we grip really tightly to the things
that we know
[Music]
um because it feels safe
and the truth is change is really really
hard because you're holding on to things
that are no longer meant for you
if this is speaking to you I want you to
write into the comments right now what
are you holding on to
whether it's out of fear or self-doubt
or overwhelm you're just gripping so
tightly
what are you holding on to that you know
is no longer meant for you I guarantee
you you're probably going to write a
friendship a job a relationship
uh maybe it's a way of eating or
treating your body
maybe it's a way of thinking that you're
holding on to maybe you're just gripping
tightly to staying stressed and tense
and in a state of fear
you can hold on to a way of thinking and
that can keep you stuck for decades
I wanted to bring this up because I have
been thinking a lot about this idea of
gripping and holding on
and I think if you if you've followed me
for a while
probably heard me say that you are one
decision away
from a different life
better life a life that is full of more
joy
full of Happiness full of you feeling
connected and alive and just engaged in
your life again just one decision away
and the first decision
that will change everything is to let go
stop ripping and to find the confidence
and the courage and the clarity to let
go of what's no longer serving you
and to turn yourself toward what you
truly want in your life rule number four
start making changes tell me is there
some project
or some area of your life
or a business or a goal or some change
that you want to make
that you feel like you think about all
the time but you just can't seem to push
through
all of that thinking or push through the
the the fatigue or the overwhelm or how
do I get started right
you can't seem to just push through is
there some area of your life where you
feel that way
if so I want you to write it in the
comments okay I see I want to work with
animals I see somebody going oh my gosh
I keep thinking about doing a tick tock
account oh I want to get control of my
addiction oh I want to launch your
business oh I really want to get a
degree but I feel like it's too late
um and you may be telling yourself uh
that uh things just feel like it's too
late Mel like I I got a divorce and now
it feels like my life is frozen I see
some of you saying I feel like ever
since I got the divorce or the pandemic
hit or I lost the job or I took the
wrong job or I moved to the wrong place
or I realized that I wanted to start
this thing and I started it but now it's
stalled out and I'm embarrassed to keep
starting I want to finish my PhD I want
to be persistent with the gym I want to
get back to creating art I see all the
stuff that you all are writing down it's
beautiful I see so many of you saying
that you have a little side hustle and
you know that you want to turn your
attention towards it but you just can't
seem
to literally push through whatever it is
the fear the overwhelm the business of
your life to laser focus
on what really matters to you
and I think that's why it's so painful
because you're not going to stop really
wanting and longing for those things
that you keep thinking about everybody
they're going to linger for the rest of
your life
you're gonna have to at some point make
a decision
that it is important enough to you
to make changes so that the thing that
you want to see happen or the life that
you don't want to miss out on
or the degree that you always
longed to get
or the way that you want to feel in your
body or the energy for me a big theme uh
recently has been about loneliness I am
so lonely in my personal life because of
the pandemic because our kids have
launched because we're moving to Vermont
because I'm always working like I can
see very clearly
that I have tried to solve loneliness in
my personal life by working all the time
and that's not the right solution for
loneliness and so I even see all this
and so
I'm glad that you can see an area of
your life where you feel this friction
and tension because you know that you
want to focus more time and energy there
but there's so much resistance and
there's so much friction and there's so
much else going on that it is robbing
you of the ability
to push forward toward the life that you
really want to be living
and look it's not going to happen
overnight but so let me tell you let me
tell you
this sentence this truth about life that
I truly love that that always kicks me
in the rear end honestly and here it is
no one is coming
that's it no one's coming
no one is going to come into your life
and do the work for you no one is going
to come into your life and uh just
remove your problems no one is going to
come into your life and uh make your
dreams come true
when it comes to the changes that you
want to make when it comes to the things
that you long for in your heart when it
comes to the music that you want to put
out into the world or the tick tock
account that you want to create or the
degree that you want to get or the life
you want to build after divorce or after
your partner dies or after you know you
change jobs or after the kids launch
when it comes to those things that you
deeply long for deserve and desire no
one's coming
you are not too late
if you're breathing you're watching this
video you have plenty of time
to create a life that makes you happy to
create a life that is full of meaning
for you whatever that means you have
plenty of time to take control to heal
it is so important for you to hear that
that you have plenty of time
but no one's coming
at some point you have to make a
decision and you'll often hear me say
you're one decision away
from a different life a better life
but you have to make the decision no
one's coming to make the decision for
you you have to decide that you are done
feeling beaten up you're done
feeling lost you're done feeling stuck
you're done feeling isolated that all
that crap that you've been enduring
you're freaking done
you have to decide that also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five prioritize
happiness when's the last time
you felt excited
because you were up to something that
was either cool or it was new or it was
exciting
you know I think about times in my life
when I was up to something
it's like those moments of anticipation
I was applying to college or I was
applying to law school or I was making a
decision that I was going to leave a job
that I didn't like or even after a
breakup you know where you're newly
single and you feel like whoa oh I love
how many of you are saying right now
right now I feel like I'm up to
something
right now you know I feel like I could
be a part of something or maybe for many
of you who are saying I don't feel that
way Mel I'm feeling like my life is
pretty stagnant it was a long time ago I
can't remember when
I want to have you imagine something
imagine
how energizing and exciting it would be
to wake up every day and feel like
you're a part of something really cool
imagine if you made a decision
that's starting literally today
you were going to be up to something you
were going to push yourself you know it
makes me kind of sad everybody how many
of you are sitting there saying
um I can't even remember I've lost my
direction
and I want to tell you something
if you feel lost if you feel stuck if
you feel like it has been way too long
since you've had something that you've
looked forward to
I um I want to tell you something
you deserve you deserve to have that
energy back in your life you deserve to
uh get the push that you need because
yet last night was a reminder of
something you know it's so easy and I I
know that I can fall into this too it's
so easy to kind of get stuck in your rut
especially after working from home for
two years especially after coming
through the pandemic especially after
being in this routine of isolation and
feeling like nothing is ever going to
change last night for me being in New
York City and uh just coming down and
being with friends and seeing how
energizing it is to be around people
that are up to something it reminded me
of this piece of research that when you
hear it it sounds kind of stupid right
but then when you stop and think about
it it's so true
when researchers study happiness you
want to know something crazy about happy
people
happy people
are just prioritizing and making time to
do the little things that make them
happy
and what we also know and you know this
too that when you look forward and you
see things in your calendar just this
weekend for example just this weekend
having something that you've planned
something that you're going to be a part
of that just having something just out
in the near future to look forward to it
gives you two bursts of energy two
number one the planning of it makes you
think about it right and as you
anticipate it and you anticipate what
something is going to be like
you get this burst of energy and then
the doing of it
makes you feel energized and excited
again rule number six believe that
you're worthy who can relate to this
you feel like you're not worthy of the
things that you're accomplishing or that
somehow this is luck or somebody's like
giving you a break but you didn't earn
it God every one of you that blows
really
so what you're dealing with when you
have imposter syndrome is you're dealing
with a lack of self-worth
you literally
kind of see all the things working out
but you've got this like annoying voice
in your head that's saying you don't
deserve this this is luck how many of
you have that story this is locked this
is going to run out this isn't due to me
yeah we got to literally destroy that
voice that is from your past
and part of the reason why you have that
boy that voice by the way is because of
racism it's because of discrimination
it's because of childhood trauma it's
because of uh various experiences that
you've had where either your experiences
growing up or Society at large has made
you feel either overtly or in a really
like gross and sort of Sly way like you
don't belong and so it is critical for
you to start to punch that voice
literally out of your head and I'm going
to give you some steps to do it okay
the second thing that's really important
is that in addition to stopping down
that voice because it's not your voice
that is somebody else's voice that your
brain listened to
and then started repeating
and the thing about your brain is that
your brain is this really cool computer
that learns patterns
and what I want you to understand is
that patterns repeat
unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what Heidi has
that says you're not worthy you don't
deserve this luck is going to run out at
some point that you know what's going to
hit the fan again
brace
don't count on anything
like you didn't earn this if you got
that pattern running in your head that
is a broken pattern
you're not broken
that pattern of thinking is broken
and so the Line in the Sand that I want
to draw starting today is you're not
allowed to listen to that garbage
anymore
we are going to go on a mission together
to notice whenever it comes up oh
interesting there it is there's that
pattern it's spinning just like a load
of laundry right up there and I'm going
to teach you once you recognize that
pattern you're going to use this thing
that I created called the five second
rule you're going to count backwards
five four three two one because that
shuts that down
and counting backwards let's all do it
together here we go five four three two
one now notice when you counted did you
feel a little pressure right here
yeah that was me hypnotizing you no I'm
just kidding
um
what you were feeling
is by counting backwards it's a little
brain hack
that interrupts all the garbage that's
here in the interior part of your brain
this is where imposter syndrome lives
everybody this is where anxiety is this
is where self-doubt is this is where
self-criticism is this is where it's all
stored when you notice oh there's that
voice again and you count backwards five
four three two one you shut it down
and then you awaken this part of your
brain this is the part of the brain that
you used when you were taking the SATs
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you applied for that job when
you speak up in that meeting when you
tell somebody no you cannot borrow my
dress tonight no when you have
boundaries right this is the part of the
brain that gives you immediate control
over what you think and do next
and so that's a really important thing
rule number seven picture a positive
future the reason why visualization and
picturing yourself succeeding and
allowing yourself to feel the happiness
and the pride that comes with picturing
a positive future the reason why that's
as important is let's say Shelley does
that every single day this week every
day she wakes up she walks for five
minutes and as she's walking on that
treadmill she's visualizing herself
finishing a 10K in six months and how
proud she is every time she does that
she is changing what's going on up here
this isn't something I made up this is
true and it's not only true based on
science but let's think about this from
a common sense perspective if Shelley
wakes up or if you wake up every single
morning and instead of thinking about
the worst case instead of looking at
your body in the mirror and going I'm so
fat I'm so out of shape I'll never run a
10K it's never going to happen why
didn't I exercise last year I hate my
flabby stomach I hate my my big thighs I
hate how out of shade I'm embarrassed
like I'm if that's what you're thinking
then that is what you're allowing your
brain to continue to filter the world
through
if you start teaching yourself the skill
of visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now is you start
to think like the kind of person that
does a 10K
if after an entire week what Shelley
does is she looks in the mirror and she
goes I'm getting stronger every day I'm
really proud of myself even though I'm
I'm feeling flabby I'm not saying you're
flabby Shelly but even though I'm
feeling flabby I'm doing the work I can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10K
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day the new mind just seven to
ten days later is going to go oh wait a
minute I'm gonna say I'm proud I'm doing
this why do you sign up
it's gonna filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why I'm so glad you're doing it rule
number eight stop holding on to misery
one of the things that I have to do is I
have to stop holding on to misery I've
got to stop holding on to my own habit
of hesitating and overthinking and
feeling scared and gripping and I'm
working on it
um so I want to know what are you
getting out of this
and I see oh I love this I see so many
of you going oh my God happiness is so
unfamiliar happiness is so unfamiliar
trauma that you haven't released I
relate to this holy cow I'm so glad that
you do
I remember
um a couple months ago I was doing a
bunch of research for
um a project that we're doing for
audible about happiness was one of the
episodes that we were working on
and it was kind of striking to me
that
the research around happiness shows that
folks that feel happier and are present
to more joy in their life have a habit
that those of us that sort of grip
tightly and feel a little wound up and
stressed and have a hard time relaxing
don't have and that habit that happy
people have is that they make time to do
things
that make them feel happy
and when I started digging into that
research it was a little confronting
because I thought holy [ __ ]
I don't even allow myself I'm so gripped
to feeling stressed out and intense and
bracing for what's next that I haven't
even made it a priority to allow myself
and so becoming a happier person again
I'm going to go back to what I said
earlier in this broadcast the first step
is literally letting go stop gripping
let go of what's no longer serving you
because holding on to it hurts a hell of
a lot more than letting go of it
and so wherever in your life you are not
happy or you are just bracing or
stressed or if stuff isn't working I
guarantee you you're gripping onto
something a relationship a job a habit a
routine a place that you live a mindset
you're gripping onto something that no
longer serves you
and gripping to it is going to cause you
so much more pain and misery than
letting go
it's really that simple
every single ending in your life has a
brand new beginning contained into it
that's it every single ending
that you are avoiding in your life
inside that ending there is a new
beginning I am right in the thick of
this which is why I'm talking about it
Rule Number Nine stop hesitating for
years hesitation
kept me trapped in my head
hesitation made me doubt myself
hesitation kept me from taking the
actions and
taking the small risks
that change your life
and you have a habit of hesitating
hesitating is this little habit that we
all have and you know I obviously
invented the five second rule which is a
tool that you can use to push through
the hesitation that holds you back
and to break that habit of hesitating
and to replace it with an action of
moving forward
but there's an area in your life where
you are hesitating
you know what you want or you at least
know you don't want what you currently
have
and you think a lot about what you need
to do or what you could do or what you
wish would happen
and all that thinking that you're doing
that is the problem
you're not going to change your life
you're not going to get what you want if
all you do is think about it
and
I want to challenge you
I think that there is some change you
want to make something that you want to
do and you're sitting there questioning
it whether it's
going back to school or launching that
business or moving to a different place
or breaking up with somebody or changing
up your exercise program
there's something that you want to do
and I want you to put in the comments
what's that thing that you really want
to have a breakthrough in or you want to
change but all you do is think about it
and think about it and think about it
maybe it's your job maybe it's your
health maybe it's your relationship
well I know one thing that a lot of you
are hesitating on right now is jumping
into this new program that I have called
launch
um I'm going to talk about it in a
minute but for those of you that are not
considering launch that's cool I want
you to get something out of our
conversation right now but the habit of
hesitating of questioning
I think it kills more happiness more
possibility more dreams than fear
failure and every excuse that you have
because it's so subtle
you see what happens to you is that
throughout your day you are going
through your day and as you bump into
people or you have experiences or you
see things on social media or you're
reading a book you have this impulse or
this inspiration this moment where
you're like oh gosh I'd really I'd love
to launch a business like that or oh I'd
love to launch a podcast or maybe I
should write a book someday or you know
whoa uh I should really get serious
about that thing that I want to do
and then
instead of taking a step forward
you stop and think about it
so I see Stephen wants to stop smoking I
see that
um you know a lot of you want to launch
your business or change your job learn
how to invest in real estate full-time
that there's a lot that you're thinking
about
but this moment of hesitation
what happens when you stop and think is
you literally get trapped in your head
and the more that you think about this
thing whether it's real estate investing
or launching a business or changing your
health or quitting smoking or
whatever it may be
maybe it's just mindset maybe you just
wish you weren't so negative all the
time maybe you wish you could be happier
that's something I'm working on in this
chapter of my life learning how to allow
myself
to be happier learning how to be okay
with everything that's happening and
everything that's not I mean that would
be a huge change for somebody like me
who is so type A and so hard charging
and so driven to learn how to just be
happy and okay no matter what's
happening
that would be enough
that's something I'm working on but
thinking about it that's not going to
help
so as you write down an area of your
life where you're hesitating I want to
tell you the simple truth
the only thing that is going to change
that relationship that job your
financial situation your attitude your
mental health your friendships your
relationship with your family the only
thing that's going to change that is
action
you got to learn how to launch through
the excuses the fear all of that crap
that's holding you back animal number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is do the things that matter
do you feel overwhelmed right now
yes oh okay I'm not the only one that
feels overwhelmed okay good
um I find it very comforting when I know
that I'm not the only person who feels a
certain way
and whether you are overwhelmed right
now
because of your job or because of your
health or because of what you're seeing
unfold in the news or the world around
you or whether you're overwhelmed
because you just have so much on your
plate you feel like you are standing
underneath an avalanche I hate that I
see so many hearts going because that's
a terrible place to be
I want to share a surprisingly simple
thing that you can do
in order to deal with overwhelm
and the reason why I say that this is
surprising
is because whenever you feel overwhelmed
isn't it true that the last thing that
you want to do is take on anything else
you're sort of like I can't do one more
thing I barely have time to go the
bathroom I'm so overwhelmed
and that's why what I'm about to
recommend is incredibly surprising
because this is going to seem like it's
super counter-intuitive
as a solution based on research and
based on for sure my personal experience
as a solution to moments in time where
you feel overwhelmed by life or by the
world or by what you're facing
now what is that surprisingly Simple
Solution as a way to deal with overwhelm
well
the surprisingly simple solution
is to take on a simple
little challenge that you're going to
take on every day you're going to take
on something
that uh
aligns with growth and change
it pushes you
forward
and it gives you something to look
forward to every day because part of the
reason why overwhelm is so debilitating
is because when you're overwhelmed your
focus is scattered across absolutely
everything
and you're thinking about your family
and your health and the news and this
and that and the presentation and the
emails you didn't do and
at the end of the day
each and every one of those things
is not really that important there's
probably can we agree one two or three
things a day that really matter
that really needs your attention and the
reason why we get so freaking
overwhelmed with life is we allow our
attention to get scattered and to get
pulled in a bazillion different
directions
and the solution
to feeling more in control and to
literally dealing with overwhelm which
is just an overwhelming amount of things
that really most of which are not that
all important to you but they're just
distracting you which then pulls your
attention away from what really matters
you see I'd rather have you do two or
three things a day that really matter to
you and let the rest just kind of fall
where they fall right and so the
surprisingly simple way to deal with
overwhelm is to pick one thing that
you're going to focus on every day for
you like no matter what you're gonna do
this thing you're gonna add a little
structure you're going to add something
that you're committing to as a way to
laser your focus on something that's in
your control it's absolutely awesome how
this works
this one is like really important you
need to do the work okay you got to do
the work because it's only through your
actions that you will accomplish what
you want let's say uh that you've always
wanted to climb a particular Mountain
okay there's a mountain called Haystack
it's not even that tall so I should
probably pick a bigger one but let's
just call it Haystack Mountain you've
always wanted to climb Haystack Mountain
you pull up to Haystack Mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know National Forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my God
that's a really far way away you know I
don't really know how I feel about doing
this anymore because that looks like
it's going to take a really long time
and then all of a sudden it starts to
rain and you go I don't think I want to
do this because I don't think I feel
like doing this and next thing you know
you are back in the car driving back
down the road to that little diner that
you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamed of
climbing you've now come up with an
excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it you pull the record you're out
of there in order to have what you want
in life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain you must stop creating excuses
for why you can't or don't feel like it
and you must put your head down and look
at the first step in front of you and
then you must take the action and start
walking toward what you want and it'll
be a hell of a lot easier for you to do
that if you have also been putting in
the time every day consistently to not
only see yourself walking up that trail
step by step but that you have felt
yourself pushing through the resistance
the fear the obstacles the excuses that
are stopping you now and feel proud in
every fiber of your being as you push
through those obstacles and see yourself
and feel yourself doing the work that's
how you manifest properly and if you do
that before you pull into the National
Park parking lot if you look up but that
mountain and you see clouds and it
starts raining it won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment and your mind body and spirit and
you my friend will start walking up that
trail
and you're going to be proud that's how
you use manifesting to get what you want
that's how you leverage all the science
and research to train and prepare your
mind body and spirit to help you get
what you want and that's how you hack
the motivation and inspiration that you
need to take the actions that get you
everything that you want and deserve in
life and one of the things that will
help you to do the work to create the
things that you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that [ __ ]
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool day let's go
do something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that I
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
Chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why I love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself well
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my God it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying [ __ ]
this I don't want to see all the reasons
why I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or relationship
and I don't want to see that and and
have my mind process it as evidence that
it's never going gonna happen for me I
want my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so [ __ ] up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the Bulls from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there number one the secret
to an app optimistic mindset you got to
be maniacal about your intake
negativity in here means negativity in
your body gets stored here and
negativity comes out here
it becomes this Loop of negativity and
so in order to build a positive mindset
I want you to be maniacal about positive
input that means really watch your news
intake do not be watching it every day
get the facts
get what you need to know from a trusted
measured
calm factual source and then turn that
[ __ ] off okay that's number one number
two edit your social media
anything on your social media feeds
should be helping you be more resilient
more optimistic
more
um positive
anything that you're following that
triggers you that is negative that rubs
you the wrong way you know one of the
things that I've noticed
I have some favorite celebrities that I
have um followed for a while because I
think they're funny or I love
um
just kind of their sense of humor
there are so many people that I have
muted right now because I think that
what they're doing online is so freaking
out of whack seeing people give us
advice about quarantining from the back
of their Estates and mansions telling us
to donate when they're not saying
they're donating seeing this kind of
tone deaf uh celebrity thing going on
I'm normally not a negative person about
that but I have muted muted muted so
many accounts because it's not doing
anything for me and you got to be
selfish right now you have got to edit
your social media feeds so that your
social media feeds are helping you build
an optimistic and positive mindset and
so every day the second I see some at
mute mute mute mute unfollow unfollow
unfollow because negativity in means
negativity gets stored here means
negativity goes out there from you you
want to put positivity optimism tools
strategies things that keep you laughing
keep things that keep you giving you
things that you can use right now the
second you start getting overloaded with
Corona stuff mute that stuff edit edit
edit your social media based on what you
need that's number one maniacal about
your intake you must visualize the steps
that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal this is a major mistake
that people make they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank or you crossing the finish line
or you launching that business or you
having the body that you want or you
would drive in the Maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the Oscars
winning that award or the Grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal you start to
feel really unmotivated and discouraged
because you're nowhere near it that's
where manifesting comes in because we're
not going to focus on the end goal you
gotta pick something that you want in
order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end it's about the
bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a Grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to Fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be but when it comes to
manifesting once you've given yourself
permission to dream with the lid off and
really want what you want to feel the
pull of that thing now we gotta talk
about the path that connects where you
are with where you want to go and this
is all about visualizing the Little
Steps there's a lot of research that
proves why visualizing the steps is the
most important thing that you could do
there was a study done at UCLA for
example where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a closed
their eyes visualize in their mind and
feel in their body
themselves taking the test and then
walking up to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an A plus that's what
group a the vision board group we're
told to do to visualize themselves
achieving what they wanted
Group B
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late and
putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it Group B
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered Group B you got the
correct answer the reason why Group B
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it lowers
your resistance and leads to you taking
the action that's why manifesting works
you know the same is true in sports
there's all kinds of research in sports
psychology in fact our Olympic athletes
for the U.S Olympic team they hire
Sports psychologists to train our top
Olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured in visualizing
themselves competing when you coach an
athlete to mentally rehearse every
single detail about going through the
competition you are training the mind
body and spirit to show up and dominate
this is is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right so manifestation
properly remember what it is manifesting
is preparing your mind body and spirit
to do the work it's aligning your mind
body and spirit with what you want it
removes the obstacles that would
normally stop you which then prepares
and motivates you to take the actions to
succeed so in the case of athletes who
visualize themselves and see themselves
doing all the steps over and over
they're removing the nerves they're
removing all the programming related to
the injury they are preparing their mind
body and spirit to go in and freaking
Dominate and so are you do tiny things
every day that boost your mood okay
so we're gonna build your mood muscle
if you can move your body because
negativity gets stored here and moving
your body we know based on the research
simply moving your body for 10 or 20
minutes a day will release chemicals in
your mind that help you boost your mood
the second thing that will boost your
mood is I want you to make a tiny
promise to yourself every day just one
thing that makes you feel more positive
is it getting up on time
is it eating something healthy is it
only having one glass of wine or
reaching for a mocktail I want you to
put one tiny promise into place put it
into the
um comments right now what's one tiny
promise that you can make to yourself
that you're going to do every day it
might just be that you're going to wake
up every day take a deep breath remind
yourself that you're healthy and that's
going to be the tiny promise I want you
to do one tiny promise every day because
keeping a promise
to yourself will boost your mood and
make you feel more in control another
way to build your mood muscle is have a
zero tolerance policy for your own
negative thoughts
right now as you edit social media and
edit your news take and edit your
negativity coming in from the outside
world
do not tolerate negativity from the
inside world I woke up this morning I
looked in the mirror
I looked at the gray hairs that are
coming in particularly like right up
here and I started to go negative I
started to feel dreary and I went Mel
cut this [ __ ] out you gotta fight to
stay positive gal because we are in this
for another couple months and do not
succumb to despair do not start thinking
native stuff when you have negativity
internally you got to have a zero
tolerance policy for that it's one thing
to feel what you need to feel
so that you can move through it it's
another thing to let negativity dwell up
here and start ruminating the five
second rule is genius for this count
backwards the second that negative five
four three two one
not listening to it no I am redirecting
my thoughts that's right I am looking
for the things I can control I am
keeping a positive attitude by focusing
on things that I can control right now
today I think I am um
engaged in emotional eating right now
uh it is 2 22 in the afternoon
and the wheels are off today
um I know why the reason why is because
I did not stick to my normal routine
and I've noticed since I did not stick
to my routine my day has sort of slid
off the rails in terms of the decisions
that I'm making
um it's really random like I had
my son's chicken nuggets for lunch and
there's half an apple that I ate I have
not finished the amount of water I
normally drink is 223 and
I made myself an ice cream sundae
because you know why the hell not and so
as I'm sitting here enjoying my ice
cream sundae I just thought to myself
God
am I emotionally eating right now
oh my God this is so good
if I really unpack what I'm feeling
right now it's raining it's freezing I
am mentally in a creative block and I'm
gonna get this tool that we use on the
Mel Robbins show out I call it the word
wheel so I'm gonna show you the word
wheel right now
here's how you use a word wheel the
average person can only name three
emotions happy sad and angry
but our emotions are actually much
deeper and more complex and the secret
to getting unstuck or untriggered or
freed up in any situation is to find the
words that describe what you are truly
feeling so I'm going to start with the
core emotion of anger and fear and work
out from there and so as I look at the
word wheel
I feel inadequate as a writer
I feel worried
that I'm not going to have a creative
breakthrough
I feel helpless the big one is I feel
inadequate as a writer whoa big
breakthrough
feeding my inadequate
ice cream sundae
you know what's interesting is simply
finding the word
I feel inadequate as a writer and that
makes me feel afraid that the book isn't
going to be good that it's not going to
be as good as I want it's not going to
do as well it's not going to get any
um accolades or good reviews it's not
going to make a difference in your life
as you identify the feeling and for me
it's inadequate that Sunday doesn't
taste very good anymore
because it wasn't a Sunday
that I was craving it was reassurance
and comfort from this deeper feeling
that I was feeling
wow that's powerful stuff
really powerful stuff
so if you are at a moment where you
catch yourself emotionally eating
or you just feel untethered or numb pull
out the word wheel you can find it at
melrobbins.com
and
um I think you'll find it to be a really
incredible tool
that will help you locate what you're
truly working through and instead of
reaching for
an ice cream sundae which honestly is
going to now tank my mood because of all
the sugar and make me feel uh lethargic
if you can identify the word which for
me is inadequate
inferior worried
um frustrated uh you can let those
feelings rise up move through them and
then move on
two hours later and let me tell you the
impact of having fed my feelings first
of all I am totally bloated so I realize
that that's not big but you know for me
my stomach is just like oh
because all that sugar and dairy that I
just pounded down is now sitting here
like a rock and this is the problem with
emotional eating because you get caught
in this cycle where you feed these
feelings and then your body starts to
tank and your mood tanks and your
stomach gets bloated and so then you
start to make yourself wrong and feel
ashamed and feel like a bad person
because you did it
laughs
so how do you stop emotional eating
and what business do I have giving any
of us advice given that I just did it
well I'm going to tell you what I'm
going to do tomorrow when I inevitably
hit that created block
is emotional eating you know that it's
emotional if it's uh comes on suddenly
if you aren't just craving something but
you are reaching for something that is a
treat or that's soothing and before I do
that tomorrow with my writer's block
inevitably happens again
I will take a deep breath and I will ask
myself what am I feeling
why am I reaching for this food am I
hungry or am I trying to soothe their
comfort or distract myself
because I was clearly trying to soothe
and distract myself from the feelings
that writer's block was bringing up and
now I need to get some Gas-X or
something
because I gotta distract myself from the
gas pains that I have for my emotional
eating
but you know honestly the discomfort I'm
feeling right now that's not going to
stop me from doing it tomorrow the only
thing that will stop this pattern is
spotting the pattern and using the tools
that I just gave you identify what
you're feeling ask you why it is you're
reaching for this if you're not hungry
but you're trying to soothe distract or
reward yourself you're feeding some
feeling
recognize the feeling put down the ice
cream go for a walk choose something
healthy address the feeling
don't reach for the food you gotta be
honest with yourself
if there are things about your
appearance that are within your control
whether it is the shape that you're in
whether it's the health choices that
you're making whether it's how you take
care of yourself in terms of self-love
and you're not taking action in those
areas the lack of action says to your
brain
you don't care about yourself and so
what I want you to do is pick one thing
one behavior that you could do every day
the high fives one of them pick another
one and I want you to practice doing it
and it's a behavior if you think about
the person that you want to become
what's that person do every day that you
don't do right now and when you start to
do the thing that the person you want to
become is doing
you leverage something called behavioral
activation therapy and that is a whole
body of research that says when you act
like the person you want to become it's
the most powerful way to change a habit
it's even uh better therapy than uh talk
therapy because the action proves to
your brain that you're becoming that
person you're seeing the change through
the action and so then the brain catches
up and starts to relate to you like a
person that's confident or a person who
adores their appearance or a person that
celebrates themselves exactly as they
are we moved to Vermont I got a brand
new uh primary care doctor
and I thought he said something really
interesting he's this great guy
um he settled here because his wife's
family uh is from Vermont and so he's
now lived here for 40 years and at the
end of my uh first appointment with them
he said a really interesting thing to me
he kind of chuckled because of course
I'm very entertaining and bubbly and all
this stuff and he said it's going to be
really fun to watch what happens to you
and I'm like
what doctor says that to somebody
and I said what do you mean and he said
well I'll tell you Mel in the years that
I've been practicing as a primary care
doctor in southern Vermont I have seen
so many people moved to Vermont
they're seeking a choir lifestyle
they're seeking a change a new chapter
and what I find is if you're what you're
actually seeking is a safe haven and
you're running away from your problems
a funny thing happens
your problems always go with you and
when you move somewhere very quiet
the Solitude just magnifies that you
were trying to get away from
and so if you're starting a new chapter
because you're excited and you're
Reinventing yourself that's fabulous
still take time to complete the last
chapter that you were in so you step
into the new chapter with all of the
wisdom and the Gratitude and the
learning and the growth that you gained
if you are starting a new chapter as so
many of us do because we are running
away from the old us we're running away
from a bad relationship we're closing
the door on something that wasn't
working
you better make sure you take the time
to think through and journal about this
last chapter who you've been the habits
you no longer want to repeat the
mistakes that you made what you've
learned what you're running from and
more importantly what changes you're
going to make and how this new chapter
is going to support you in doing it and
in becoming the person that you're meant
to be without that intentional moment of
reflection and without that intentional
moment where you're going to list out
the behaviors and thinking patterns and
habits you're changing
my doctor's right you're just going to
take all that crap you're running from
right into this new chapter I wanted to
make this video because I know in some
area of your life you are wanting to
start something you're wanting to put
yourself out there more and you are
holding yourself back and one place that
I see this playing out all the time is
the fact that so many people probably
you are self-conscious and nervous about
putting videos online your
self-conscious and nervous about talking
about your business or sharing the
breakthroughs that you're having or just
showing up in a bigger Bolder more
self-expressed way because heck it makes
your life more fun when you do and so
you have this deep yearning to be doing
more and then I know exactly what
happens to you you look at the number of
people that follow you you then say who
the hell am I to say that you then go
nobody's going to watch it anyway and I
want to share with you brand new
research that blows that lame excuse
although normal excuse right out of the
water it was published literally this
month from Ohio State University and it
proves that when it comes to video
content the video content that people
find compelling
has nothing to do with the number of
views that it has it has to do with the
person and the message that's being
communicated to be compelling to make an
impact to be influential because I know
everybody wants to raise their influence
and their visibility and to show up in
bigger ways it is all about the message
and you're in control of that do you
communicate with passion do you have
conviction about what you're talking
about you could be talking about oh I
don't know uh whether you like white
cords or these like black cords with
this end or whether you like this kind
of end or this end or where you're like
this cap or whether you oh I love to
drink this way because I have a big nose
and then this way
and I'm telling you you don't have to
have this thing on you could literally
talk about anything and if you bring
passion and you bring conviction to what
you're talking about
people will pay attention that's what
real influence is it's the ability to
show up in ways and have conviction and
passion about the things that you
believe in whether you're talking about
a water bottle cap or you're talking
about how to be healthier happier or
more effective in your life so enough
with the excuses enough with worrying
about how many followers you have or
whether or not Aunt Sue is gonna like
the video or not or what people are
gonna think
the only thing that matters is the
conviction and passion that you
communicate with and of course getting
started so based on the research
get started put that video out the
coolest thing about jealousy okay
embrace it
let me tell you why okay you are only
jealous of the things you authentically
want so for example for a long time in
my life I was super when we were
struggling financially I was super
jealous of anybody that had a big house
or was putting on an addition and I
didn't know what to do with my jealousy
so it would consume me I tell the story
in this book of going uh into a friend's
brand new you know house at a time in
our life where Chris's restaurants were
failing and I was unemployed and we were
like profoundly in debt I was it nearly
made me self-combust in This Woman's
kitchen okay and how did I deal with my
jealousy because I didn't know what it
was we get in the car and what do you
think I did for my poor husband why
aren't you more successful I should have
married somebody in finance like she did
why are we in this situation like you
just like aim it at people right because
you don't know what to do with it
my jealousy was not about a house
when I finally started to unpack it it
was about my ambition
and so you cannot be jealous of
something you don't want
if I believe that jealousy is blocked
inspiration I've never heard that before
it is blocked by your fear it is blocked
by insecurity it is blocked by you have
this deep ins like you have this and and
like you said it earlier I'm really
jealous of this idea Mel I wish I had
come up with it you have a new book
coming out I'm not going to say what the
title is but here's what I want you to
take away from it
there's something about the simplicity
of the idea right that makes you jealous
that is what your inspiration is trying
to get you to pay attention to
be good so I'm jealous of you you got
this show
you have the discipline to do it all the
time you're translating it into a
podcast I've been sitting on my ass
talking about doing a podcast for four
years
what the old Mel would do before I
understood jealousy is because it's
blocked by insecurity I would then tell
myself a story
you're too late
it's already done there's not enough
room for you if you do it you're a
copycat all of that just blocks what you
really want really true pay attention to
your jealousy and stop and unpack it
what really is it about that person is
it their marriage is it the way that
they're being treated is it how they
take care of themselves what is it about
Financial Freedom and anybody that has
it that makes you feel jealous really
get to the core of what feels right for
you and then get to work on it you can
choose
what you tell yourself about a situation
that's happening
but it was helpful for me when I started
to understand
that your emotional waves
and your nervous system response happens
before your thoughts appear
and so it's really important for
everybody to realize you will not be
able to control
the fact that there will be moments when
you're disappointed moments when you
feel rage moments when you feel betrayed
moments when you feel pissed off moments
when you feel shortchanged moments when
you feel aggravated and these waves come
over you you will never be able to
control those from coming up
but you can choose
what you are going to tell yourself
about what's happening
and the other thing is is that when it
comes to trauma I mean all of this is
sort of dysregulation in your nervous
system that's stored there that keeps
getting retriggered and so if you're
dealing with a trauma response
you will not be able to also think your
way through it first
and part of what has really helped me is
when I started to understand oh the wave
of emotion and feeling comes before my
brain can actually help me get back in
control and so when I started to
understand that oh there's going to be
these waves of emotion don't resist them
let them come what you said by the way
was so strong that we will celebrate
other people but we won't celebrate
ourselves until we feel like we have
done something yes
you have done something every single
morning you've woken up in your
breathing
that's it
like think about what it's like to walk
into a crowded room and nobody says
hello to you
we've all had that experience right of
walking into like think back to Middle
School
when you walk into the cafeteria and
you're looking for a place to sit and
nobody acknowledges you
like you just want to disappear in that
moment yeah I'm telling you you have
made yourself feel like that
and so there is this moment in the
mirror where when you see yourself and
you celebrate and high-five yourself
you're acknowledging your own existence
because you've literally been ignoring
yourself we you talk about these themes
all the time in on the show of self-love
and self-confidence and self-awareness
and we've all heard that phrase you got
to put your oxygen mask on first you got
to put yourself first
nobody knows how to do it
and you do it by fulfilling your own
needs and you can start every day doing
it you can use something called the
vagus nerve and a tool that I like to
talk about is called high-fiving your
heart so you put your hands right here
right like in the center of your chest
over your heart and you say these three
words you say I'm okay I'm safe I'm
loved
I'm okay I'm safe I'm loved and when you
put your hands here you are toning and
activating What's called the vagus nerve
the vagus nerve runs all the way from
your seat to the top of your head
through every major organ through your
vocal cords and it is the key it's the
switch between your fight or flight
state of anxiety and your calm state and
so first things first you want to
develop a practice first in the morning
not only of high-fiving yourself in the
mirror which we're going to get to which
is all about self-confidence and
self-esteem and self-love and self-worth
but you're also going to wake up every
morning put your hands right here and go
I'm okay I'm safe I'm loved here to say
it as many times you have to 113 11
times two times until you actually feel
your body settle down
and you will you will feel yourself
ground back into your body you will feel
something shift and if you can hear
yourself saying those words I'm okay I'm
sorry if I'm loved
it's true in that moment and by putting
your hands right here this is what
activates the vagus nerve other things
that help you tone the vagus nerve and
ice back a hot shower a hot bath
singing gurgling humming chanting
because it stimulates your vocal cords
and so this is a little tool you can use
I love doing it first thing in the
morning but you can use it anytime you
feel anxious to settle yourself back in
your body when you're a kid your parents
force you to do the things you don't
want to do
get out of bed make the bus eat your
vegetables be nice look the people in
the eye turn your homework in don't talk
about like all the things you need to do
right and what is really interesting
about becoming an adult
is nobody tells you when you become an
adult now it's your job
nobody is coming to save your ass nobody
is going to tell you to get out of bed
nobody is going to do the work for you
nobody's rescuing you nobody's
discovering you it's up to you and
here's the other piece that nobody tells
you you're never going to feel like it
by the time you're 18 you are already
stuck in your ways you're stuck in your
story about yourself you're stuck in the
habits that you have many of which you
picked up by either witnessing what your
caregivers were doing or reacting and
trying to survive the situation that
you're in with your caregivers so you
have a whole set of patterns that you're
stuck with
your brain is designed to repeat
patterns
and so now you have a choice
you either live with the patterns that
you have or you spot them and you
freaking break them and replace them and
this is why you're never going to feel
like doing the things that you want to
do and you have to parent yourself
because your brain will always default
to its its patterns and so from this
point forward here's what you should
assume
I will never feel like doing the [ __ ] I
need to do ever so stop waiting to feel
like it stop waiting for motivation stop
waiting for inspiration to strike you in
the ass and get make you get off the
couch and finally take the advice that
you're giving and take care of your
health stop waiting to feel like you're
going to turn off Netflix and do the
kind of evening routine cycle to make
sure that you're going to get a great
night's sleep stop
if you want an amazing life you're going
to have to work for it if you want to
change you're going to have to break
patterns and the number one rule that is
going to help you is to assume you are
never going to feel like doing that
stuff so stop expecting it and push your
freaking ass to do it and you can use
the the five second rule count backwards
five four three two one that'll help you
break the pattern in habit research it's
called a starting ritual that interrupts
an old pattern and prompts your mind to
focus on a new one and then you move
that is the only way to change just like
your parent was annoying get up the bus
is coming I don't care you're not
getting up from this table until that
plate is clean
you didn't feel like getting it but you
did so that tells you something you are
capable
you just don't feel like it here's the
thing about morning routines I think
morning routine Envy is a real thing and
I do believe that a lot of people lie
about their morning routines I think
lying about your morning routine is a
real thing I think pretending you have
the perfect morning routine is a real
thing
um
I'm
I'm about when I'm home I'm almost 80
percent in my morning routine I get it
done because it's super simple right so
I mean I think I need a simple one yes
and when I'm traveling
I almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses I think
the key to having a morning routine and
morning routines are critical because
how you start your day
has a massive proven impact on how your
day turns out there's one piece of
research that I think is really profound
and this comes from Sean anchor I talked
about this yesterday but I'm going to
tell you
um this too Susie if you consume three
minutes just three minutes of negative
news
of negative television of negative
emails maybe stressful emails from work
or stressful texts from friends you have
more than a 50 percent chance eight
hours later to say you had a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind it literally sets your mind
up to be on the lookout for things going
wrong and so the reason why a morning
routine is is actually so important is
because number one it determines what
your priority for the day is
and we also know based on Research that
you removed in the morning it impacts
your productivity all day long just
because you identify and for me as a kid
for whatever reason I have my own
version of feeling invisible and feeling
like I'm not good enough and so my way
of coping both with my anxiety and being
a survivor of sexual abuse and
um
and wanting love which we all need is I
was like an overachiever and so I'm the
kind of person that's super busy and a
go-getter because it got me attention
and if I was the one that was super busy
and achieving I not only got praise but
it also insulates you from other people
not picking you because you're the one
in a leadership role doing the picking
right and so there's a part of me at the
age of 51 that is realizing that you
know this these feelings of feeling
unworthy and this hyper drive to try to
achieve it's all coming from a place of
feeling inadequate or like what I'm
doing is not enough and so that's 50
having a talk show having a best-selling
book having the audible Originals having
the platform everywhere having the
impact is still don't feel being the
most booked female speaker in the world
like you still don't feel so stupid it's
annoying and human beings are annoying
we are stuck with this wiring like if
you think about it like all of the crap
you believe is is probably a hangover
from age zero to ten
that as adults we walk around thinking
the same stuff we thought as kids and I
can't stand that I feel that way
but knowing it it allows me to catch it
before it has me before it stops me from
having an event or writing that next
book or taking a risk now here's a trick
about gratitude writing down what you're
grateful for doesn't work unless you do
it this way because if you if I ask you
what you're grateful for everybody says
the same thing I'm grateful to be alive
I'm grateful for my health and I'm
grateful for my family
and that's so generic that you're not
retraining your brain right you've got
to add in the because
I'm grateful for X because and the added
detail will make you change up
what you say and it will also train your
mind in a way that's more detailed so it
actually has a lasting impact on the way
that you view the world
everything that I have done since since
we launched the five second rule book
was in reaction to things that were
coming to me so I never sat out and said
hey the five second rule audiobook has
been a complete uh like record breaker
we clearly have an audio audience let's
go pitch audible audible came to me
which is fantastic
um I never I always dreamed about having
a talk show but I wasn't out pitching
one
Sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into courses online courses
and we now have more than a half a
million people that have taken our
courses online
um
was because Success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together
remember I was there to view you for it
oh and I was I hated it because what I
discovered is I hate being told what to
do and so but that gave me the idea oh
we should do courses ourselves and so
this pause has made me stop and go what
do I really want to do
and the the truth is I want to go and
make the biggest possible impact that I
can and I want to collaborate with more
people and I want to do events
um and I
I don't want to be the CEO I'm a
terrible leader horrible leader the
worst actually
um because I'm amazing at coaching I'm
amazing at uh creating I'm amazing at
reacting I'm terrible at managing people
I am terrible at managing a project I
have ADD I have dyslexia
um I'm a bulldozer when I get anxious
um
we kill each other if we were roommates
or business partners but but I think
understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that I've decided number
one I'm going to consciously create the
next check yeah and what is that and I'm
um well I'm still in the middle of doing
it yeah but you're one of the events you
want to do these things you're talking
about yeah yes and I wanna I wanna
collaborate more with a wider audience
of people um and I want to build a brand
bigger than Mel Robbins yep I don't want
it to just be me I want to build a
platform based business that uh reaches
more people because here's the thing
that has got that got me through kind of
the loss of the talk show and the way
that I think about things that I hope
helps
um if you're listening yeah kind of
struggling with something
um I believe and I went into the talk
show saying this to myself because
there's a 99 chance based on the history
of people that have tried to have a
daytime talk show that was going to fail
and I went in there saying
this I'm not doing this because I expect
to have a successful talk show I'm going
to put a thousand percent into it so
that I have no regrets and I wouldn't
change a thing but I'm going into this
because I know that there is a skill a
person or an experience I am meant to
have
that will help me
for the next chapter that I can't see
coming
[Music]
because you
know I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
recent interview with Mel Robbins one on
one check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I hope
your business goes bankrupt Evan Evan
you're a terrible person I spent the
first 40 some years of my life trying to
be somebody else I'll give you guys a
secret way